up next we got aunt and Madeline this is
aunt Madeline well goddamn Madeline
family your phone's on low battery and
you in the bathroom getting ready
charging it up let's see y'all up and
roll up a little bit oh it's just a
counter I can't see though she's a lot
going on the counter she'll see going
out took a picture for a man before she
went out or someone she's in too that's
what's going on here could you not send
this to a friend your friends don't give
up [ __ ] let's flop mom what did they say
about the information any information
with endurance she likes playing guitar
making people laugh and she loves dudes
with mullets hmm she has the same
birthday as a theodore von is seeing him
at the brea improv in August oh don't
leave me yourself to just the modeling
about me Brandon okay she seemed like a
nice lady
she's Pisces is that kalila though I'm
wondering does look like Bobby Lee's
girl and who's his often she often
flirts with me when I'm on their show
this is awkward fer to slide into our
show like this cuz Bobby's probably
gonna see it really when's he gonna see
it dude he's awake for 40 minutes a day
he's a koala bear
yeah dude sleeps 90 hours oh he's our
call he's always just he's you just
smell the eucalyptus on his breath dude
that guy and I caught him eucalyptus and
dudn't ended up with this lady that
could happen Bobby wake up Bobby the
long nap Li baby so we don't long nap
short [ __ ] they call him dude do you
know I'm not Matt this Aunty and she's
also feeling my boy over here so gang
gang girl buzz buzz young lady thanks
see what I can do though thank you for
reaching out yeah I'll see what I can do
I listen if you asked I'll do it I'll
play a love matchmaker I'll do that I'll
be your [ __ ] what's the name Chris
had any hana we host the show who hosts
the bachelor no it's Benny I'll be your
Chris Hanson Chris Harrison no Chris
Hanson I'll go like this come on in take
a seat why do you have my cards lemonade
in your car yeah see oh camon drink what
are you doing
what do you weigh of a batch of we have
a [ __ ] full batch of hamsters he has
his own what are you doing what are you
doing we have sweats what are you doing
with your sweats there
what did a bunch of hamster teeth made
up necklace he don't like that [ __ ] this
[ __ ] he likes what do you have a picture
of a shirtless Dustin Poirier here he
has that he has that girl Jesus Christ
man why do you have a bag full of warm
condoms because you left him on the
windshield they were sitting in the
direct sunlight okay okay let me yeah
now I'm gonna read the some of your text
to this thirteen-year-old oh I want to
jack you off all night long did you say
that they like no I don't mean jack
their penis off yeah I mean the
controller the video game we're playing
yeah anyways I'll see what I can do for
you girl we'll see well but I will do
that for you too but only never Brendon
she sent a picture I know I'm gonna be
your Wonderwall I'm gonna be the filter
that she has to get through well I'll be
your white Walker I will do that for you
no use in this journey of love I will be
your white Walker what yeah I'm gonna
protect you from from the crazies dude
no dude you're bromius handsome your bro
me oh and I'm fully yet bro
okay that's the truth dude and I ain't
fallin for New Year [ __ ] ah dude I'm
gonna take care of this for you hey OH
first of all Bryn's kind of guy when he
winks he has to obey he has to open his
mouth pop look at me keep your mouth
closed when you wank you creep you look
like you're in a coma and they ask you a
question you're trying to answer it
that's how you look you don't know how
to wink at people do you supposed to
wink like this where's your whole body
go with it dude cause it's a it's a sign
of appreciation dude all I'm saying if
you were trying to meet a nice young
lady I will be that filter I will be
that love net for you that they have to
get through to get to my friend Theo yay
if you're a filter bro its Rio de
Janeiro all right I'll do that Brio days
since we're here I'll do that no you're
the [ __ ] not a filter dude the last
time I'll be your Klondike bar
oh dude I would rather freeze to death
somewhere broccolini get your life
together